in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for May 7th, on which we commemorate our Holy Father
Alexis Toath of Wilkes Bar, Pennsylvania. The memory of Saint Alexis Toath of Wilkes
Bar, Pennsylvania. Confessor of Orthodoxy in America.
Born in 1854 of a Carpathian Russian clerical family, belonging to the Greek Catholic
Union Church, Saint Alexis was given an excellent education and learned a number of foreign
languages. Or dained a priest shortly after his marriage, he very soon lost his wife
and their young child. And he then s forth devoted himself completely to his pastoral calling.
Appointed secretary to the Union Bishop of Presove, he both ran an orphanage and taught
church history and canon law in the seminary. He was sent to the USA in 1889 to serve in
the parish of Minneapolis, Minnesota. Having taken up his charge, he went to report to
the Roman Catholic Archbishop, who, being opposed to the existence of national communities
in America, received him with open hostility and refused to recognize his credentials.
Father Toath opposed this unjust decision, but he had to face the United Policy of the
Catholic Bishops, who were afraid that the Union communities would be opposed to the emigrants
assimilation into American culture. In expectation of expulsion, Father Alexis
explained the situation to his parishioners, but refused any sort of servile submission and
advised him to approach the Russian Orthodox Bishop in San Francisco. After several visits
to each other, Bishop Vladimir received Father Alexis and 361 of his parishioners into the
communion of the Holy Orthodox Church in 1891. And, sometime later, the parish was incorporated
into the diocese of Alaska and the Alliution Islands. This example gave encouragement to hundreds
of other immigrants from Eastern Europe, and Father Alexis's ardent sermons about the Orthodox
Church persuaded them to return to the Church of their forefathers. Although inflexible in matters
of faith, Father Alexis always exhorted his parishioners to avoid all condemnation of others,
and intolerance towards the heterodox. At the cost of great toil, he published many writings on the
Orthodox faith and of pastoral teaching for the newly converted. His conversion, however,
brought him many enemies, and he was accused of selling his compatriots to the Muscovites for
financial gain, he who was forced to work in a bakery until he received a salary from the Russian
Church. He who, despite his meager resources, never failed in almsgiving and who shared his money
with other poorer priests, confiding himself to providence for all his needs. Father Alexis sought
only the kingdom of God and his righteousness, and bore all affliction with joy.
The Orthodox bishops in America recognized his talents and virtues, and often sent him to
preach to the Orthodox Slavs dispersed around the country. He also visited many uniyat parishes,
explaining the difference between the Orthodox, the Catholics, the uniyats, and the Protestants,
and thus played his part in the return of 17 American parishes to the bosom of Orthodoxy.
When he came to the end of his labors, thousands of Carpathal Russians and Galicians had returned
to the Church, providing the Levin for the expansion of Orthodoxy in the New World.
Having been honored with the number of ecclesiastical dignities and decorations, Father Alexis
was nominated to the Episcopate in 1907, but he refused, suggesting that in his place a younger
candidate in better health be elected. At the end of 1908, his health deteriorated, and after a
stay by the sea, he fell asleep in peace on the 7th of May in 1909. During his illness, he never
stopped interceding for the confirmation of the true faith in America. His relics are
venerated today in the monastery of St. Tikhon and South Canaan, Pennsylvania. Through the prayers of
our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.